PROFESSOR: So we've
been saving for the last
the property that makes
expectation calculating
really easy and short circuits
a lot of the ingenious methods
that we've used up until now--
namely, expectation is linear.
So what that means is that if
you have two random variables R
and S and two constants a and
b, the expectation function
is linear.
That is, you take a linear
combination of R and S-- aR
plus bS, and that's equal
to the corresponding linear
combination of the expectations.
I'll read it again.
Expectation of aR plus
bS is equal to a times
the expectation of R plus
b times the expectation S.
Expectation is linear.
OK.
That's an absolutely
fundamental formula
that you should be
comfortable with and remember.
It extends actually not only to
any finite number of variables,
but with some
convergence conditions,
it actually extends even to
accountable sum of variables.
But let's just settle for
the two random variables
case for today.
Now, the crucial thing that
makes it so powerful and useful
is that this fact has nothing
to do with independence.
Whether R and S are independent
or equal, it doesn't matter.
This linearity holds.
The proof is not
terribly informative.
It's just manipulating terms
and rearranging terms into sum,
but let's go through
the exercise.
Again, something I would
never do in lecture.
But in a video where you
can skip it or fast forward
or replay it, I think
it might be worth doing,
And it is a proof, by
the way, that I think
you should be responsible for.
So let's go through it.
OK.
We're interested
in the expectation
of the random
variable that you get
by multiplying the
random variable A
by little a and the random
variable B by little b.
All right.
One of the definitions
of expectation
is that you get this expectation
by taking the sum over all
the outcomes of the value
of this linear combination
at the outcome omega times
the probability of omega.
So what's the value of the
linear combination aA plus bB?
At omega, it's simply a
times A of omega plus b
times B of omega.
OK.
Now I've got a sum of these
terms summing over omega.
I can split them
into two groups.
I can take the sum over
the aA's at omega times
probability of omega
and bB of omega times
probability of omega.
In other words, I'm multiplying
by probability of omega
here to get a sum of
two terms, and then I'm
rearranging all of the
capital A terms first,
followed by all the
capital B terms.
The result is that I wind
up with the sum over omega
of the A terms times the
probability of omega--
and I factored out the little
a-- plus b times the sum
over all omega of B of omega
times the probability of omega.
It's just rearranging
the terms in this sum
after I've multiplied through
by probability of omega.
Well, of course, this is
equal by definition to a times
the expectation of A. Notice
this is the expectation of A,
and that's the
expectation of B times b.
And the proof is done.
Not inspiring, but routine
if you use the alternative
definition of
expectation in terms
of summing over the outcomes.
It's a messier proof
if you have to use
the definition of
the expectation,
being the value
times the probability
that the variable
takes that value.
And you wind up having
to convert that formula
into this formula in order to
carry through the proof nicely.
And we're done.
OK.
Let's make use of it.
And in order to do
that, let's make
a really trivial
but a very important
remark about the expectation
of an indicator variable.
So remember I sub A is three
random variables that's
equal to 1 if the
event A occurs and 0
if the even A doesn't occur.
So what is the expectation
of the indicator variable?
Well, by definition, it's
1 times the probability
that it equals 1 plus
0 times the probability
that it equals 0.
Those are the only two
values it can take.
Well, we can forget this
term in 0 times something.
But what is the probability
that I A is equal to 1?
That's exactly the
probability of A,
and that's the fundamental
formula that we want to notice.
The expectation of the indicator
variable for the event A
is nothing but the
probability that A occurs.
File that away.
We're about to use
it multiple times.
So let's go back to the
expected number of heads in n
flips which we've now seen
at least two ways to do-- one
by generating function argument,
another by a recursive argument
using total expectation.
Now where we're going to knock
it off very elegantly using
linearity because let Hi
be the indicator variable
for having a head on ith flip.
So we look at the ith flip.
Hi is 1 if the ith
flip comes up head
and Hi is 0 if the ith
flip does not come up head.
Then we can make the
following crucial remark,
and this is a trick
that we'll use regularly
by expressing some
quantity that we're
interested in as a sum
of indicator variables.
The total number of
heads-- the random variable
equal to the total number
of heads in n flips--
is equal to the sum
of the indicator
variables for whether there's
a head on the first flip plus
whether there's a head
on the second flip
up through whether there's
a head on the n flip.
So suddenly the random
variable that I want to compute
is a sum of n random variables,
in fact, n indicator variables.
All right.
Well, that tells me
that the expectation
of the number of heads is
the expectation of the sum.
After all, it's
equal to the sum.
But the expectation
of the sum is
going to be the sum of the
expectations by linearity.
So it's simply the
expectation of H 1
plus the expectation of H 2 out
through the expectation of H n.
But what's the expectation of
getting a head on ith flip?
Well, the flips are independent.
It's simply the
expectation of a head.
So what I have
is-- each of these
is equal to the probability of
a head, and there's n of them.
So the total is n times the
probability of Head, or np,
which is a formula
that we had derived
two other ways previously.
And now it really falls
out very elegantly
with hardly any ingenuity
other than the wonderful idea
of expressing the number of
heads as a sum of indicators.
Let's look at one example
and a very related example
of asking about the probability
of the expected number of hats
that are returned.
When n men check their
hats at a hat check
and then the hats
get all scrambled up
by incompetent staff
and then they're
given out again in such a
way that the probability
that the ith man gets his
own hat back is 1 over n.
What you could say is that all
possible permutations of the n
hats are equally likely.
And we ask with all
permutations equally likely,
how many of them is it
the case that the ith
man gets his own hat back?
And there's a 1 out of n
chance that the ith man
is going to get his own hat
back because there's n hats,
and he's equally likely
to get all of them.
OK.
How many men do we expect
will get their hat back
in this setting?
Well, let's let our Ri be
the indicator variable for
whether or not the ith man got
his hat returned-- R i for hat
returned to the ith man.
Now, notice that Ri and
Rj are not independent.
In the previous case,
those H's were independent
because the coin flips
were independent.
But here, if I
know, for example,
that R 1 got his hat
back, the probability
that R 2 got his hat back
has changed from 1 over n
to 1 over n minus 1 because
1 is out of the picture,
and R 2 is going to get his hat
back among the remaining hats 2
through and n is
n minus 1 of them.
And he's got a 1
minus 1 over n minus 1
chance of getting his hat.
His probability
has changed given
that R 1 got his hat back.
So they're not independent.
All right.
Nevertheless, independence
doesn't matter for linearity.
So I can still say that
the expected number of hats
returned is equal
to the expectation
of the sum of the indicator
variables for each man
getting his hat back.
And of course, the
expectation of that sum
is the sum of the expectations.
And the expectation of each
of these-- we figured out--
was 1 over n, and
there's n of them.
So it's n times 1 over n, or 1.
I expect when all the
hats are scrambled
and all permutations of the
hats are equally likely,
that one man is going
to get his hat back.
None of the others will.
OK.
Now let's change the
situation a little bit.
And think instead of
scrambling the hats in a way
that all possible permutations
of hats are equally likely,
let's think about
a Chinese banquet.
So Chinese banquets
are traditionally
done with a table
of nine in a circle,
and there's a lazy
Susan that spins around
where there's dishes of food
in front of each person.
But let's generalize it to n.
Suppose that n
people are sitting
around a spinning
table-- a lazy-Susan)
with n different dishes, one
dish in front of each person.
And now we spin the
lazy Susan randomly,
and we ask how many
people do we expect
will wind up with the
same dish that they
started with after the spin?
Well, now we can let Ri
indicate that the ith
person got the same dish back.
And now these Ris,
which are different
from the previous ones
about hat returns,
these are Ris are totally
dependent-- much more
so than the other ones
work because they're all 1
or they're all 0.
If one person gets
their hat back,
it means that the
spinning table got
back to where it used to be, and
everybody has their hat back.
And if one person doesn't
have their hat back,
then the table is shifted
off where it was originally
and nobody has
the original dish.
I said hats.
I meant the dish that
they started with.
So everybody gets
the same dish back,
or nobody gets the
same dish back.
These variables are as dependent
as they possibly could be,
but it doesn't matter because
linearity still holds.
And that means that
the previous argument
about the expected number
of dishes that get back
to the person that
they started with
is still 1 even though
all the Ris are equal.
Well, that's so much for the
lovely rule about linearity
of expectation which holds
regardless of assumptions
about independence or not.
There is a rule for products,
but it requires independence.
So the independent product
rule says, sure enough
that the expectation
of a product of two
random variables, x
and y, is the product
of their expectations, providing
that they are independent.
And this extends
to many variables
if they're mutually independent.
Again, the proof by rearranging
terms in the defining
sum for the expectation of xy.
Let's go through it.
And again, you can fast
forward or skip this part
if you don't want to watch
equations being manipulated.
So by definition, the
expectation of the product xy
is the sum over all
the possible values
of x and y of the
value of the product
xy times the probability that
the first variable, capital X,
equals little x and
the second variable Y
is equal to little y.
This is by definition, the
expectation of the product--
by the first definition.
Not the one in
terms of outcomes.
Now, using
independence, this term
here can be split into a product
of X equals x and Y equals y.
So let's do that.
So this is the sum of
xy times the probability
that X equals x times the
probability that Y equals y.
Now I'm going to do a
fairly standard trick, which
is I'm going to organize
this sum in a clean way.
Right now it's an unordered sum
over all possible pairs of x
and y in the range of
the variables x and y,
but I'm going to do the
sum so I first sum over all
the y's, and then for each
y, I'm going to sum over all
the x's.
This is an unordered
some really.
There's no order here, but now
I'm giving you an arrangement
which says that I'm going to
lump together the sums over all
the x's, and then for each of
those I'm going to sum up over
the y's.
Well, when I do it
this way, what I've got
is an interesting thing here.
I've got a sum over x, and
there's some y terms here
that don't depend on x.
I can factor them out because
they don't change with x.
So if I factor out this y and
probability of Y equals y,
I wind up with the sum over y
of this factored out term-- y
times probability Y equals
y-- times the sum over x's x
times the probability
that X equals x.
Now, this is the
same term that is
the coefficient of every
one of these y terms
that depends on y, and this
term does not depend on y.
So I can factor it out.
And if I do that, I
wind up with the sum
over x of x times
the probability
that X equals x times
the sum over y of y times
the probability that Y equals y.
And guess what.
This is by definition
the expectation of X,
and this is by definition
the expectation of Y.
And by that chain
of equalities, I've
proved, sure enough, that
the expectation of XY
is equal to the expectation of X
times the expectation of Y QED.
So the key step here
was where independence
was used at the very first step
when I split up the probability
that X equaled x and Y
equaled y into the product
of the corresponding
probabilities.
Now, let me just
end with a warning
about a couple of blunders
that people make all the time.
So first of all, don't
forget independence
as a crucial condition on the
product rule for expectations.
It can hold in some cases where
the variables are dependent.
Independent is not a
necessary condition.
It's efficient, but
you need some kind
of a condition in order for
the product rule to hold.
So if you're not
careful, it won't if you
forget to check for
independence or something that
is tantamount to it.
So let's just take an
easy example remember what
happens if independence fails.
Suppose I have a variable X--
a random variable X-- which
takes positive and negative
values with equal probability.
So it takes 1 and minus
1 with equal probability.
It takes pi and minus pi
with equal probability.
I don't really care
what those values are
as long as it's taking some
positive and negative values,
and it takes a positive
value at the same probability
that it takes that
value negated.
Well, that automatically means
that the expectation of X
is 0 because when I
add up all these terms,
the positive and negative
terms cancel because they
have the same probability.
So any such X that's symmetric
about 0 has expectations 0.
On the other hand,
if I square X,
then all of those positive
and negative values
become positive.
And so I'm taking
the expectation
of a variable that's
strictly positive-- at least
with nonzero probability
at a bunch of outcomes.
And therefore, the expectation
of X squared is positive.
So the expectation of X
is 0, but the expectation
of X squared is positive.
Well, of course, if I
multiply expectation
of X times expectation
of X, that's still 0.
So here's a counter example.
Expectation of X
times expectation of X
is equal to 0, which is
less than the expectation
of the square of X. Of
course this is about as
dependent as it could
possibly be because it's
the same random variable,
but it illustrates
the failure of the
product rule if you
don't have some kind of a
condition like independence
around.
There's a second blunder
that's more interesting
and that people can fall in
because there's a temptation
to assume that if the
product rule holds
for independence, then so
should the reciprocal rule.
That is, you might think that
the expectation of X over Y
is equal to the expectation
of X over the expectation of Y
when X and Y are independent.
But it's not true.
Even when they're
independent, the expectation
of X divided by Y is in general,
not equal to the expectation
of X divided by the
expectation of Y. In fact,
the counterexample is if X is
the constant 1, the expectation
of 1 over Y
[AUDIO OUT]
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
complex instruction
set code was better than risk.
So I won't mention names,
but prominent people
have made this blunder.
You shouldn't.